let's now design the algorithm for
solving the genome assembly problem
let's have a string and the it's
three-mile composition which is a set of
all three months generated from the
string if we represent each camera as a
node then the genome is a path through
all the nodes but can we construct this
path without knowing the genome but only
from its composition well yes we can we
simply need to connect two cameras if
they overlap by K minus one in this case
for example we have taa and AIT here we
connect by Nash because they overlap by
a a let's try to follow this idea so we
connect all the nodes without overlap by
two months is it all can we construct
the genome path already
no there are more connections because
these cameras also overlap by tumors
can we still fry the genome path in this
graph I can how this is the way please
note that I cheated a little bit here
because these nodes are ordered
according to their positions in the
genome well in reality the position
information is not available
so if I slightly reordered the nodes in
this graph then the task is more
challenging for example in this case
nodes are arranged from left to right in
lexicographic order so the genome is
actually a walk
in this graph yes and this path actually
what is what are the thing that we are
trying to find we are trying to find the
path that traverse every note exactly
once and we count a path that visit each
node in a graph exactly once a
Hamiltonian path in the graph if the
Hamiltonian path problem is that for a
given graph we need to find a path that
visit every node in the graph exactly
once for example let's look at this
graph this is a directed graph it's
their Hamiltonian path in this graph yes
there is but it's a little bit tricky to
fight here it is indeed VT this is
actually the game invented by William
Hamilton a great mathematicians but
Hamiltonian path can also be applied for
non directed graph also where there is
no arrow on the edge